Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
About 350 episodes ago in this series, in
episode number 8, we talked about an amazing
paper in which researchers built virtual characters
with a bunch of muscles and joints, and through
the power of machine learning, taught them
to actuate them just the right way so that
they would learn to walk. Well, some of them
anyway. Later, we’ve seen much more advanced
variants where we could even teach them to
lift weights, jump really high, or even observe
how their movements would change after they
undergo surgery.
This paper is a huge step forward in this
area, and if you look at the title, it says
that it proposes multiplicative composition
policies to control these characters. What
this means is that these complex actions are
broken down into a sum of elementary movements.
Intuitively you can imagine something similar
when you see a child use small, simple lego
pieces to build a huge, breathtaking spaceship.
That sounds great, but what does this do for
us?
Well, the ability to properly combine these
lego pieces is where the learning part of
the technique shines, and you can see on the
right that these individual lego pieces are
as amusing as useless if they’re not combined
with others. To assemble efficient combinations
that are actually useful, the characters are
first required to learn to perform reference
motions using combinations of these lego pieces.
Here, on the right, the blue bars show which
of these these lego pieces are used and when
in the current movement pattern.
Now, we’ve heard enough of these legos,
what is this whole compositional thing good
for?
Well, a key advantage of using these is that
they are simple enough so that they can be
transferred and reused for other types of
movement. As you see here, this footage demonstrates
how we can teach a biped, or even a T-Rex
to carry and stack boxes or how to dribble,
or, how to score a goal. Amusingly, according
to the paper, it seems that this T-Rex weighs
only 55 kilograms or 121 pounds. An adorable
baby T-Rex, if you will. As a result of this
transferability property, when we assemble
a new agent or wish to teach an already existing
character some new moves, we don’t have
to train them from scratch as they already
have access to these lego pieces. I love seeing
all these new papers in the intersection of
computer graphics and machine learning.
This is a similar topic to what I am working
on as a full-time research scientist at the
Technical University of Vienna, and in these
projects, we train plenty of neural networks,
which requires a lot of computational resources.
Sometimes when we have to spend time maintaining
the machines running these networks, buying
new hardware or troubleshooting software issues,
I wish we could use Linode. Linode is the
world’s largest independent cloud hosting
and computing provider, and they have GPU
instances that are tailor-made for AI, scientific
computing and computer graphics projects.
If you feel inspired by these works and you
wish to run your experiments or deploy your
already existing works through a simple and
reliable hosting service, make sure to join
over 800,000 other happy customers and choose
Linode. To reserve your GPU instance and receivea
$20 free credit, visitlinode.com/papersor
click the link in the description and use
the promo code “papers20” during signup.
Give it a try today! Our thanks to Linode
for supporting the series and helping us make
better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!